hi everyone
this is professor mda science and today
i want to talk about commutator algebra
in another one of our videos on rigorous
quantum mechanics operators in quantum
mechanics
don't always commute a consequence of
this is that the commutator of two
operators becomes a key quantity in
quantum mechanics
the most famous one is the canonical
commutation relation
between position and momentum but the
importance of commutators goes well
beyond this
the aim of this video is to explore some
properties of commutators
with two objectives the first is to
learn a number of relations involving
commutators of operators that will prove
extremely useful
in our study of quantum mechanics and
the second is that this video should
provide good practice for you to become
more familiar with both
operators and their commutators let's go
the key quantity today is the commutator
the commutator of two linear operators a
and b
is written between square brackets like
this and is equal to the product a b
minus the product ba
if you've seen commutators before you've
probably seen the one between position
and momentum operators
which is equal to ihbar however
commutators are central in quantum
mechanics and appear in many other cases
beyond positional momentum
today's video is pretty straightforward
we'll prove a number of results
involving commutators
this will serve a double purpose first
it will provide a good reference for
results that we use constantly in many
other videos
and second it will be good practice for
you to become more familiar with
manipulating commutators and operators
which is a very important skill when
studying quantum mechanics
the strategy i'll follow is that i'll
quote the result that we want to prove
at the beginning of each slide
and only after i will go on to prove it
so a good way for you to approach this
would be to pause the video at the
beginning of each slide
have a go yourself at proving the result
and only checking the answer afterwards
the first relation we want to prove is
that the commutator of a and b
is equal to the negative of the
commutator in the reverse order
again if you want to have a go at this
before you check out my proof
just pause the video here otherwise
let's get started with the proof
the left hand side is the commutator of
a and b
expanding the commutator we get a b
minus ba
we can now take out a common factor of
minus 1 to get minus b
a minus a b and this is simply minus the
commutator of b and a
and this completes the proof
the next relation says that the
commutator of a with b
plus c is equal to the commutator of a
with b plus the commutator of a with c
for the proof we can start with the left
hand side
expanding we get a times b plus c minus
b plus c
times a multiplying through these
brackets we get four terms
a b plus ac minus ba
minus c a reordering we get a b
minus b a plus ac minus ca
these two terms give the commutator of a
with b
and these two terms give the commutator
of a with c
and this completes the proof
the next relation is that the commutator
of a with b times c
is equal to b times the commutator of a
with c
plus the commutator of a with b all
multiplied by c
for the proof we start again with the
left hand side
expanding the commutator we get abc
minus bca
for the next step we first copy the
first term abc
we now subtract and add the same term
minus bac
plus b ac over all these two terms add
to zero so i'm just adding zero which is
something i can do
and we finally have the final term minus
bca
starting with the first two terms i will
take c as a common factor
and for the next two terms i'll take b
as a common factor
we can now see that the brackets are
commutators so we get this commutator
times c plus b times this commutator
and this completes the proof this
relation doesn't look as simple as the
one we've discussed earlier
but actually is extremely useful in
quantum mechanics so you'll find
yourself using it all the time
for this reason it's worth remembering
it and there's actually a relatively
simple way to do that
what you do is you first write down all
possible commutators that only involve
two operators
while keeping the operators in the same
order as in the original expression
in this case we only have the a operator
in the first entry
and then the b and c operators in the
second entry
which leads to two commutators one here
and one here
what you do next is that to each term
you add the remaining operators outside
the commutator
and the key point is that we need to
respect the order of the original
products
in our case c here has to multiply from
the right
because it goes after b and b here has
to multiply from the left because it
goes before c
a related result is that the commutator
of a b with c
is equal to a times the commutator of b
with c
plus the commutator of a with c times b
the proof follows the same line as the
one we just did so i will not repeat it
here but feel free to have a go yourself
and again you can remember this relation
by using the same strategy we just
discussed for the original relation
and this is the final relation i want to
consider the adjoint of the commutator
of a
and b is equal to the commutator of the
adjoint of b
with the adjoint of a to say this we
start again with the left hand side
we next expand the commutator as usual
and we can rewrite it as two separate
terms
the next step relies on a general
property of the adjoint of a product of
two operators
x y which is equal to the adjoint of
each operator
in reverse order if you can't remember
this property we actually proved it in
our video on adjoint operators so you
can just follow the link in the
description
by using it here we can write the first
term as b dagger a dagger
and the second term as minus a dagger b
dagger
putting this together we get the
commutator of b dagger with a dagger
and this completes the proof
and this is it here i have the list of
commutator algebra relations that we've
just derived
we use these relations constantly in
quantum mechanics so make sure you have
them at hand
as you can imagine there are plenty of
other useful commutation algebra
relations
and here i have additional ones we
haven't proved today however all the
proofs work along the same lines of what
we've seen today
so if you want to get extra practice i
would encourage you to have a go at
proving some of these yourself
just like before it is relatively easy
to remember the form of these
expressions
if we take the second one as an example
we can follow the same strategy we
discussed earlier
we first write out all possible
commutators of only two operators
which in this case involve a with b a
with c
and a with v we then add all remaining
operators outside the commutator while
respecting the order of the original
expression
so in the first term both c and d go to
the right of the commutator because they
come after b
in the second term b goes before c while
d goes after
c and in the third term b and c both
come before the
overall this is a rather long number of
commutator algebra relations so you may
wonder how to approach this
what i would say is that although it
isn't essential to memorize them doing
so can be very convenient
because you'll use them a lot
commutators feature in many problems you
can see the relations with derived today
in action
in some of our other videos and as
always if you like this video
please subscribe